en el último vídeo empezamos con una
línea a la cual le llamábamos directriz
así que déjame dibujar una línea por
aquí ya esta línea le voy a decir que es
la directriz y por cierto tener como
ecuación asociada
igual a camps y además nos tomábamos un
punto por aquí el cual decíamos que era
un foco y tenia coordenadas a como ven y
entonces en el vídeo pasado nos
preguntábamos por cuáles eran todos los
puntos que cumplían que la distancia a
este punto llamado foco y la distancia a
esta línea llamada directriz era la
misma que puntos eran equidistantes
tanto al foco como a la línea recta y
encontramos que todos los puntos que
cumplían esta propiedad todos los puntos
de la forma xy que bueno cumplían que la
distancia de este punto llamado foco a
este punto x como ayer y la distancia de
este punto x como ayer a la recta igual
acá era exactamente la misma era una
parábola y de hecho encontramos esta
ecuación asociada que tenemos justo aquí
esta ecuación fue lo que encontramos
como ecuación de una parábola y nos
dimos cuenta además con un buen de
álgebra que trabajamos en
del pasado que esto que tenemos aquí se
parece a la ecuación de una parábola y
por lo tanto dijimos que era una
parábola ahora bien en este vídeo
quiero ver justo lo contrario quiero
verdad a una parábola cómo puedo
encontrar su foco y su directriz y bueno
podemos empezar con un caso particular
muy sencillo con justo este ejemplo el
ejemplo que más podemos conocer de una
parábola y es igual a equis cuadrada
aquí el coeficiente que está al lado de
la equis cuadrada es un 1 eso quiere
decir que 1 entre 2 por ver menos acá
tiene que ser exactamente igual a 1 y
déjame borrar este 1 porque parece una
potencia y no quiero que nos confundamos
es decir la constante que está al lado
de la equis cuadrada es un 1 por lo
tanto tenemos que 1 entre 2 por ver
menos acá es igual a 1 y luego fíjate
que esta misma ecuación la puedo
escribir de la siguiente manera esto es
exactamente lo mismo que escribir que
menos 0
esto es igual a 1 que multiplica a x
menos cero elevado al cuadrado estas dos
expresiones son exactamente lo mismo
qué estoy haciendo se agregando unos
ceros por aquí porque entonces me van a
servir bastante para saber dónde están
las coordenadas del foco en ecuación de
mi direct es porque darte cuenta de lo
siguiente este cero que tengo aquí es
igual a por que yo tengo la forma x
menos a elevado al cuadrado y aquí tengo
x menos será elevado al cuadrado por lo
tanto puede decir que a vale 0 fíjate
como ahora vamos al revés
ahora tenemos que la ecuación es x
cuadrada e igualdad es cuadrada y lo que
quiero saber precisamente es dónde está
el foco y dónde está la directriz y
bueno aquí tengo menos 0 y aquí tengo
menos b más cada entre 2 por lo tanto
quiere decir que ven más que entre 2
tiene que ser exactamente igual a cero
entonces debemos escribirlo aquí antes
de que se me olvide de más acá entre dos
también tiene que ser igual a cero y
fíjate que estoy encontrando estas
ecuaciones según un ejemplo particular
que tengo aquí y es igual es cuadrada
para que ahora sí pueda encontrar tanto
mi foco como una directriz y es que date
cuenta de algo muy importante si ahora
empezamos con ye igual hay que es
cuadrada o ye igual a cualquier otra
para
ocurre va a ser lo contrario a este
problema que vivimos la vez pasada aquí
decíamos tengo un poco tengo una
directriz cuáles son los puntos que son
equidistantes al foco y la directriz
ahora vamos al revés ahora ya tengo yo
una ecuación de una parábola está ya sé
que es una parábola la hemos visto
varias veces es como una parábola por
excelencia y ahora lo que quiero
encontrar es cuál sería mi coordenada de
mi foco y cuál sería la ecuación de mi
directriz y bueno para eso entonces
vamos a hacer un poquito de álgebra con
estas tres ecuaciones que acabo de
encontrar lo único que estoy diciendo es
que la constante que está al lado de la
equis cuadrada es decir uno tiene que
ser uno entre dos por ver - campo esto
es justo lo que habíamos encontrado en
el vídeo pasado y después dijimos que a
es igual a cero porque a es el número
que está al lado de la equis cuando yo
veo esto como x menos 0 elevado al
cuadrado y ve más k entre 12 es igual a
0 porque no tengo nada al lado de la jep
y bueno ya que tengo estas tres
ecuaciones entonces cómo puedo sacar el
valor de b y de camps porque el valor de
a ya lo tengo a vale cero entonces yo sé
qué
entre dos volver menos k esto es igual a
1 por lo tanto voy a escribir de la
siguiente manera 1 es igual a 2 x ven
menos acá lo único que hice fue
multiplicar ambos lados de la ecuación
por 2 por ver menos acá y bueno esto
quiere decir que un medio es igual a
menos que estoy pasando dividiendo este
2 todo esto sale de mi primera ecuación
un medio es igual
avn - acá ahora aquí ya tengo una
ecuación y por otro lado tengo esta
ecuación de aquí de más que entre 2 es
igual a cero y si de esta ecuación pasó
del otro lado el 2 me va a quedar que
ven más acá es igual a cero porque 2 por
0 es 0 entonces lo voy a escribir aquí
ven más acá es igual a 0 y qué creés ya
tengo un sistema de dos ecuaciones con
dos incógnitas fácil de resolver porque
qué crees cada menos acá se eliminan y
solamente me queda 2 b y desde el lado
me queda un medio y bueno si yo quiero
saber el valor deben entonces tengo que
dividido entre 2 me va a quedar que b es
igual a un cuarto es decir la mitad de
un medio y perfecto sí ya sé que p es
igual a un cuarto entonces 0
a un cuarto más acá y de aquí puedo
despegar acá acá va a ser igual a menos
un cuarto déjame ponerlo por aquí acá es
igual a menos un cuarto porque un cuarto
menos un cuarto me da cero y entonces ya
la hice porque ya tengo el valor de a de
y de acá por lo tanto déjame ver si lo
puedo graficar para ver qué es lo que
encuentro aquí tengo un plano cartesiano
y lo primero que voy a poner es la
gráfica de mi parábola que es igual a x
cuadrada que por cierto ya conocemos
bastante bien esta de aquí va a ser
igual a x cuadrada la hemos dibujado
bastantes veces así que déjenme ponerle
nombre y es igual a x cuadrada y
entonces ya que tengo esta ecuación que
por cierto habíamos dicho que es lo
mismo que ya menos 0 es igual a 1 x x
menos será al cuadrado
estas dos expresiones son exactamente lo
mismo y al graficar las me dan esta
parábola y ya que tenemos la gráfica
entonces podemos ver que el foco está
situado justo aquí y porque el foco está
situado justo aquí bueno declarantes de
hablar del foco déjame pensar en el
vértice el vértice de esta parábola que
habla hacia arriba es el punto mínimo de
esta función y como cuento
bueno pues de ver si tiene como
coordenadas esta de aquí y esta de aquí
o dicho otra manera para que el valor de
x esta parte derecha en ecuación se hace
0 y para que valor de esta parte
izquierda de la ecuación se hace 0 y si
te das cuenta pues se nota que cuando x
vale 0 y ya vale 0 esta expresión se
hace 0 y 0 entonces aquí tengo mi
vértice b de vaca y de bert se si una
parábola abre hacia arriba como en este
caso entonces su vértice es el punto
mínimo mientras que si la parábola hable
hacia arriba entonces su vértice va a
ser su punto máximo
ahora bien regresemos al principio y
fíjate muy bien aquí fue donde partimos
y dijimos que mi foco tenía coordenadas
a b la era muy fácil sacarla porque era
esta misma que tenemos aquí es decir en
este caso avalia 0 mientras que la b la
sacamos con estas ecuaciones y además
habíamos partido de que teníamos una
línea recta llamada directriz de la
forma que igual acá y acá terminó
logramos encontrar con estas ecuaciones
por lo tanto ya sabemos que este punto
tiene coordenadas a como ven
y vale un cuarto lo tenemos justo aquí
vale un cuarto por lo tanto estamos en
el punto cero un cuarto aquí adentro de
mi parábola está mi foco mientras que mi
directriz está recta igual acá pero acá
vale menos un cuarto por lo tanto mi
directriz es la recta de igual a menos
un cuarto que es justo esta que voy a
dibujar aquí esta es mi directriz de
igual a menos un cuarto y tiene toda la
lógica del mundo porque si te das cuenta
y estamos parados aquí en el vértice la
distancia del vértice al foco de aquí
acá hay un cuarto mientras que la
distancia del vértice a la directriz
también hay un cuarto que es justo en la
definición de esta parábola y perfecto
ya lo logramos ahora para este ejemplo
particular qué va a pasar si yo lo que
quiero es encontrarlo de una manera
general es decir que para cualquier
parábola que yo te den encontremos su
foco y su directriz a partir de la
ecuación de la parábola es decir voy a
generalizar este ejemplo anterior y para
generalizar este ejemplo que tengo aquí
abajo entonces así este espacio y por lo
tanto voy a borrar todo esto para darle
un poco más de espacio
también voy a borrar lo que estaba aquí
abajo vamos a hacerlo de una manera
general para cualquier parábola entonces
tengo esta ecuación que encontramos en
el vídeo pasado y es una ecuación
bastante importante así que la voy a
volver a escribir para ponerla un poco
más en orden porque aquí ya está
bastante sobre escrita así que déjame
ponerla por aquí y qué color será bueno
elegir el color siempre es lo más
difícil de todo esto y aquí tengo voy a
poner un color amarillo un poco más
claro ya menos ve más acá entre dos esto
es igual a 1 / 2 x b menos k 1 / 2 por
ver menos camps que a su vez multiplica
a x menos han elevado al cuadrado
tengo esta parábola y bueno dada esta
parábola nosotros lo que ya sabemos es
que la directriz es de la forma igual
acá lo que queremos saber es cuánto vale
kahn y que el foco está en las
coordenadas a coma b esto por
construcción y justo es lo que queremos
saber el valor de k el valor de a y el
valor de b así que me voy a tomar una
parábola de la forma más general de este
mundo no voy a tomar la parábola
y en menos de 1 y ojo estoy poniéndole
uno porque voy a suponer que mi vértice
está en x1 y uno ni vértice está situado
en x 1 y 1 y bueno que menos uno es
igual y aquí era justo lo mismo en lo
que acabamos el vídeo pasado y teníamos
el problema de esta a mayúscula que voy
a poner aquí no confundas estaba
mayúscula con esta minúscula está
mayúscula es una constante cualquiera
así que no hay que preocuparnos
demasiado por esta mayúscula porque el
final es el coeficiente que está al lado
de la siguiente expresión de x menos x 1
elevado al cuadrado xx1 elevado al
cuadrado
y bueno si tenemos esta ecuación de mi
parábola general
lo primero que sí podemos ver es que el
vértice está en x 1 y 1 y ahora una vez
que ya tengo a esta ecuación lo que me
voy a preguntar es cómo puedo encontrar
los valores de acá de ahí de ver si yo
lo que sé es de 1 a y x 1 y lo padre del
asunto y lo mismo que vimos en el
ejemplo que vamos a hacer es que
a es igual a x1 afonso me tiene que ser
igual a x1 y ya al menos tenemos el
valor de a a siempre va a valer x1
perfecto ahora fíjate bien a mayúscula
tiene que ser forzosamente esto que está
aquí al lado es decir el coeficiente de
esta parábola tiene que ser igual a 1
entre 2 por b menos acá a mayúscula es
igual a 1 entre 2 por ver - acá perfecto
ya sabemos otra cosa y ahora fíjate lo
siguiente si tengo aquí de menos de 1
por lo tanto ven más k entre 2 usando el
color rosa tiene que ser igual h 1b más
que entre 2 tiene que ser igual al de 1
déjame ponerlo aquí ya 1 es igual a b
mas k entre 2 y ahora tras lo que voy es
encontrar de manera explícita a b ya que
es decir como encontrar una fórmula que
siempre nos sirva para sacar a bellaca
si tenemos a mayúscula y ya llevo 1 y
bueno para esto voy a hacer un sistema
de ecuaciones así que de esta primera
actuación que tengo aquí lo que voy a
hacer es multiplicar por b menos las dos
partes de mi ecuación
queda menos que multiplicar es igual a
un medio y después voy a pasar
dividiendo está a quedarme acá es igual
a 1 entre 2 a y bueno ahora me voy a
fijar en esta otra ecuación y para esto
pues voy a cambiar de color me queda que
dos veces llevo no es igual además acá
lo único que hice fue pasar este 2 del
otro lado de la ecuación y bueno tengo
dos incógnitas dos ecuaciones por lo
tanto debo de tener alguna solución y
tengo b más acá es igual a dos veces de
1 b - k es igual a 1 entre 2 am y a ver
que me quedan 2 b porque está menos que
ahí está acá se cancelan 2 b estoy
sumando estas dos ecuaciones es igual a
1 entre 2 am más dos veces y 12 b es
igual a 1 entre dos más dos veces de uno
y si paso dividiendo este 2 me va a
quedar que p es igual a esto entre 2 es
decir 1 entre 4 am
y uno porque el 2 con el 2 se cancela es
decir tomamos la coordenada de nuestro
vez se lleva 1 y esto sumamos 1 entre 4
a que fue justo lo que pasó en el
ejemplo que vimos en el ejemplo que
vimos que ya aburre o no perdón perdón
así que pueden revisarlo de nuevo porque
ya aburre este ejemplo pero bueno ya que
tenemos el valor de b que tiene todo el
sentido del mundo y ahorita lo van a ver
de una manera gráfica como encuentra el
valor de campo bueno yo sé que vale 1
entre 4 a más de uno lo voy a
cuadricular y ahora lo que voy a hacer
es tomarme a 9 tomar la segunda ecuación
y voy a despejar de aquí acá que justo
es esta que tengo aquí b vale 1 entre 4
am más de 1 entonces me queda 2 y 1 es
igual a 1 entre 4 am más de uno ya esto
le sumamos que más de uno más acá y
bueno si yo resto llevo uno de ambos
lados de la ecuación este se cancela
éste se va y me queda y uno es igual a
esto o dicho de otra manera de uno menos
uno entre 4 am es igual acá que por
cierto tiene todo el sentido del mundo y
déjenme atraparlo porque ya aquí tenemos
cuánto vale can be ya de una manera
explícita that adecuación de una
parábola ya podemos encontrar el valor
de acá y debe y es más déjeme graficar
lo para que veas qué tan lógico suena
esto yo a partir de esta ecuación ya
menos de uno es igual a por x menos x
uno está elevado al cuadrado y bueno voy
a suponer que mi parábola crece hacia
arriba es decir es una parábola que
habla hacia arriba de igual manera sirve
así muy parábola abre hacia abajo pero
bueno por esta ocasión voy a suponer que
mi parábola habla hacia arriba así que
déjame hacer la gráfica lo mejor posible
y lo que sé y lo que ya habíamos visto
es que esta es la ecuación de esta
parábola y mi vértice que voy a poner
aquí es el punto x 1 y 1 y es el punto x
1 y 1 por qué date cuenta es lo
siguiente si yo pongo aquí ya 1 esto se
hace 0 y si yo pongo aquí x 1 esto se
hace 0 y bueno a continuación lo que
quiero que veas es algo muy interesante
si nosotros tenemos que acá es igual a
que uno menos uno entre 4 a quiere decir
que en mi directriz lo único que hay que
hacer es bajar
1 entre 4 veces de este punto que
tenemos aquí es decir la distancia que
hay de este punto que es mi vértice a mi
directriz es uno entre 4 y que tiene
todo el sentido lógico de este mundo y
por lo tanto déjenme graficar aquí mi
directriz mi directriz recuerda que era
de la forma igual a camps pero ya
sabemos cuánto vale que acabamos de
encontrar que acá vale esto de aquí y
por lo tanto mi directriz que va a ser
esta línea de amarillo que voy a dibujar
justo ahorita aquí ya tengo mi ecuación
de mi directriz que es exactamente
pararme en el punto y 1 y bajar 1 / 4 a
la distancia que hay de este vértice a
mi directrices 1 / 4 am y qué crees en
foco está en el punto x 1 lo único que
estoy haciendo es cambiando mi valor en
game si recuerdas mi foco tenía
coordenadas a como ven desde un
principio sabíamos que avale x 1 y bbva
le de uno más uno entre 4 am y 1 más 1
entre 4 a que tiene toda la lógica del
mundo lo que estoy haciendo subiendo la
misma cantidad es decir la distancia del
vértice al foco también es 1
4a y esta es la parte más interesante de
todo este vídeo para que te des cuenta
que realmente no está tan difícil
encontrar el foco y la directriz de una
parábola dada la ecuación de la parábola
así que vamos a hacer un ejemplo para
ver qué tal nos quedan ya menos de 1 es
igual a nose 2 veces x menos 3 esto
elevado al cuadrado y bueno pues vamos a
graficar esta parábola para ver rápido
donde está su foco y dónde está su
directriz así que voy a hacer mi plano
cartesiano y lo primero que me voy a
preguntar es donde está el vértice de
esta parábola y para encontrarlo me
tengo que fijar en estos dos valores en
este y en éste y el vértice un parábola
está en el punto 3 1 así que uno dos
tres uno y aquí están y vértice y
después lo voy a fijar en a me voy a
fijar en la porque cuando voy a
encontrar la distancia de este punto de
mi vértice al foco ya la directriz y
bueno como a expositivo entonces me doy
cuenta que mi parábola abre hacia arriba
y voy a calcular cuántos uno entre
cuatro am es decir uno entre cuatro por
dos que es un octavo
y este un octavo me sirve bastante
porque entonces la distancia del vértice
al foco es de un octavo esta distancia
es de un octavo y la distancia de mil
vértice a mi directriz es de un octavo
por lo tanto ya puedo dibujar mi
directriz mi directriz va a ser esta de
aquí y ya tengo todo el vértice el foco
y la directriz y más o menos la gráfica
de esta parábola se va a ver más o menos
así y espero no haberlo confundido
bastante con todo esto que tengo aquí mi
idea era solamente enseñarte que es muy
fácil encontrar el foco y la directriz
de una parábola si sabemos la ecuación
de esta parábola pues si nosotros
calculamos uno entre cuatro veces vamos
a encontrar la distancia del vértice al
foco y del vértice la directriz y
entonces ya es muy fácil encontrar la
gráfica de esta parábola y una vez que
tenemos esto pues ya hemos acabado y
todo sale del importante 1 entre 4 y así
que espero que no haya sido bastante
confuso y nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo